you want to know a little more about ecology
to adopt a little more responsible behavior
and maybe change your daily habits a little bit
I give you a list of accounts to follow without further delay
attention everything happens on the other application
in 1 I would like to talk to you about Reboul
who is better known as the committed young man
basically what I like a lot in his account
is that it does prevention for the ecology
he also provides a lot of information in
telling current events and he will also denounce certain practices
as for example when the total boss obtained the Legion of Honor
he will question this kind of thing
it will also make you aware of certain things
for example it tells you that if you do a waste collection it's cool
but while your waste collection
there is a garbage truck that is poured into the sea every minute
basically what I like is that it won't make you feel guilty
it will just make you realize that something is wrong
that it is sometimes much deeper
that the small gestures that we will put in place on a daily basis
it also tries to make a difference in the political class
and I think that's very cool
even if obviously it takes a long time to put in place
in 2 I would like to talk to you about goodvest
is a start-up that offers responsible savings
with life insurance products
but also a retirement savings plan
what I like is their communication in fact
well we don't know when we invest money
we don't know where it goes and it's a little bit opaque
and well they will make you realize that sometimes your money
it will finance fossil fuels and not very cool companies
they also make much more generic content about the environment in general
and give for example recos of books
chocolate recos to learn about it and it's pretty cool
small big up in the format that I love which is the analysis of the investment
depending on a series character in particular I had liked a lot
the investor profile of the Desperate Housewives
you also have the account the small gestures
basically the concept
is to propose cool alternatives for
try to adopt more responsible behavior
you also have a seasonal fruit and vegetable calendar every month
which I think is pretty cool
and finally I would like to talk to you about the Others and recto-verso
so recto-verso it is the new media which has just launched
Others is an account that raises awareness about ecology in general and that
position of alternatives to more responsible travel
and recto-verso is the same concept but more focused on the adventure
it's really the very beginning of their account
if I can give you some advice
also subscribe to the newsletter
they make very very quality content on it
especially during the 1st edition I received a night train guide
it was really ultra complete and gave me lots of adventure ideas
quite responsible if you want to travel and at the same time
time to respect the environment